time for the power rankings all right
ready to are you ready to tear me up
over the power rankings
i've started doing these while watching
monday night football i used to do them
on tuesday morning
i now kind of get into a groove while
watching monday night football and and i
get a good sense of where
teams need to go and i was inspired by
you the other day with your challenge
about the steelers
i've decided to cluster the undefeated
teams at the top wow
long enough if you're undefeated you're
getting one of the prime spots three
undefeated teams left
seahawks titans steelers you're the top
three teams in the league yeah i like
that
i i mean i agree with you you know again
yeah we can sit here and talk about the
steelers schedule it's not the greatest
it doesn't matter they're winning
and that was their first big test the
other night uh the other sunday
and they beat the crap out of the brown
so yeah good for you
honestly mike in your top five right now
i look at it i mean i really like your
top five i'll tell you the thing i'd
probably do differently
and i know this is hard to do i'd
probably
i'd probably move the seahawks to five
and bump everybody up a spot
i mean i really i look at those four afc
teams at two
three four and five i think again the
complete
team conversation is what i keep getting
into here
all those teams can kind of do
everything there's not one glaring
weakness on those four afc teams
we know yes russell wilson and that
offense are
are serious and awesome but man that
defense is seriously bad
to where i just think as a team right
now i probably wouldn't put them in
the same uh area as the titan steelers
chiefs and ravens
and you know i don't necessarily
disagree with that they're at number one
because they've been at number one and
i've got a thing about moving the team
out of number one until they lose
which they almost did in their last game
on a sunday night against the vikings
but when you made that point and i
envisioned those other four teams bump
up my thought was
the super bowl is going to stink this
year i mean who from the nfc
is going to hang with one of those teams
i know who i know who has a chance of
doing it
there's one team that has a chance of
doing it and you know who i'm talking
about yeah tampa
i mean this is why this is who we've
been talking about again tampa's not a
finished product but
the more you watch them you start to go
the same thing we just said about the
afc teams you go
there's really not a glaring weakness i
know they're secondary you know people
getting on me on twitter
because i've made some of these comments
lately like well what about their
secondary they're like yes i get that
i'm not saying they're perfect right now
but i think you and i would both agree
or anybody watching football
it's gotten better every week and it
gets to the point sometimes where you go
whoa they look amazing like you're not
going to be able to move the ball on
this defense or
whoa their offense can do anything they
want
they can run the ball play action pass
quick passes
that's where i i mean the buccaneers and
the saints
are still two teams where i know you got
them at 8 and 9 where i still got like i
just got a little mark next to him to go
watch out because they have that
complete team mentality too and they're
just not hitting on all cylinders yet
yeah i agree with you it's about
projecting as we think about who can
compete in january
where they will be then right and the
buccaneers and saints
are poised to keep climbing and i'd say
the buccaneers even more than the saints
i'm curious to see what the saints will
be like when michael thomas comes back
i'm curious to see whether or not they
can get the situation with michael
thomas under control they had to
kind of sort of suspend him last week
even though officially it wasn't a
suspension it was a
one-game fine they need to be sure that
he's on board they need to be sure they
don't have a problem and you know what
there's another wild card out there we
talk about complete teams we talk about
teams that may have needs
antonio brown's a week and a half away
from being available whoa
and i just wonder i wonder who's going
to make that play
who's going to do it for reasons that
are
he makes us better who's going to
consider doing it
for he's gonna make that team held a lot
better
i'd rather get him on our team instead
oh i i i mean
listen he's still you know
yeah we'll see where it goes but i i
wouldn't like
think like antonio brown's physical
abilities falling off a cliff or
anything
not to say i'm expecting the superstar
we saw two years ago or anything like
that but
you know if a team wanted to take that
chance
he's certainly going to help your
football team as far as what he can do
on the field and then
you know there's there's teams again
like we've talked about
where out of these top five out of these
top six teams
you know the seahawks they got to be
like all right well yeah okay can our
defense really get that much better or
we should we just go all in on offense
and make another play for a receiver and
just go
we're down to go 40 37 every game we
don't care
you know that's hey antonio brown julio
jones
aj green if i'm the seahawks the ravens
the packers right
now i am looking at those guys to see
can i get a trade done to get those guys
because i feel like i'm in a super bowl
team
and i just need that one other player to
kind of put us over the hump there
uh i i think that's gonna be interesting
to watch here in the next few weeks
and last year the seahawks reportedly
were looking at
antonio brown at the time that they
signed josh gordon and they still have
josh gordon he's just not cleared to
play
you have to wonder are the seahawks
thinking about it and that's where it
becomes
three-dimensional chess because if the
seahawks are looking at
this possibility and it makes them
better and you know tom brady wants
antonio brown in tampa
and and bruce arians doesn't and
they've got a great array of receivers
but if they're not healthy
right yeah then how do you make the
argument we shouldn't have antonio brown
if i'm tom brady i'm like hey bruce i
understand that you've got mike evans
and chris goblin and scotty miller and
and and and we've got gronk and but
every week one of these guys isn't isn't
healthy
i think bruce is brown's never injured
yeah that's i i
scarred from two years with antonio
brown exactly and probably the other
horror stories he heard from pittsburgh
steelers coaches after he left and all
that to where i think he's so
he's heard so many things he's probably
like i'm not dealing with that
but but you know but you know what maybe
bruce arians can be worn down
if he says hey tom
you're responsible for him yeah that
good work we'll go get him
but he's he's your responsibility and if
it doesn't work it's on you
and you're going to be the one who has
to go tell him get the hell out of here
yeah
you have to keep him in line and if you
don't you have to tell him
see you later yeah and listen tom tom
could probably pull that off
tom is amazing with the team he really
is you know he's got special leadership
qualities you know that he really does
and he's
found he's obviously bonded with antonio
brown yeah get him there put him up in
like one of the suites in the jeter
household there
on hillsboro bay and here we go
but but it is it is i think uh
intriguing to consider
th that mindset you know did the saints
get back in it they brought him in for a
workout
right is is he a guy that helps their
offense
do the packers take a look at him is
aaron rodgers banging on the door saying
hey one of these other teams is going to
sign this guy
i really do think the nfc teams they're
the ones need him more than the afc
teams
because they understand what they're
going to be up against when it's the
titans the steelers
the ravens or the chiefs in the super
bowl yeah i agree i mean
i look at the seahawks and packers i
just don't think you're going to be able
to sit there and depend on your defense
you got to go
all right you know the strength is we're
going to win with our quarterback our
offense
you know just like we saw again on on on
saturday or sunday with with green bay
the game doesn't fall the right way you
know that just they don't have enough
weapons to go around
and that's where they need another guy i
will say the ravens are another team
where you know i saw the comments
yesterday they were talking about the
bye week right they were going to take
time to work on the passing game
you know two weeks ago when they played
the bengals i felt like they had a game
where they kind of were like
we're gonna throw even though we think
we can run we're gonna work on the
passing game i like that
they i think are another team that needs
i i would like to see them
dabble in the wide receiver conversation
because
again they get in the playoffs with the
chiefs and the titans
they're not going to be able to just
think we're going to steamroll these
team and run them over
there's no way the chief's got big
physical dudes up front
they can hang in there with the ravens
up front as we've seen
and they can make it okay lamar you have
to pass to beat us
so do the titans and that to me is going
to be the big question about the ravens
as we get in the playoffs if somebody
slows down that run game can lamar and
his right arm and that passing game
help carrying them over in that one game
they need it and
so far it's been no through the lamar
jackson era
and you know there was some public
jostling by guys like lamar jackson and
hollywood brown antonio's cousin to get
antonio on the team
and i poked around the edges of that a
little bit i don't think the
the teams right and
i'm not so sure that lamar and hollywood
aren't just being
courteous hollywood still has to have a
relationship with his cousin
but you know the reality is you bring a
guy in who's going to want the football
i mean that you you've got you've got to
be able to manage a guy who's going to
come in
and want the football and when
lamar and hollywood are so much younger
than antonio and maybe inclined to defer
to him
i don't know that that's the right way
to go yeah you need a spot like tampa
where tom brady 10 years older
plus than antonio brown and has that
relationship that they forged very
quickly during his limited time in new
england
whatever that relationship is if antonio
brown is going to be deferential to tom
brady i think that's going to work
wherever antonio brown goes he needs to
be willing to defer
he needs to be on a one-strike situation
and he needs to not feel emboldened to
behave the way he did in pittsburgh
or the way he did with the raiders
because that's one of the reasons why
he's in his current predicament chris
yeah no
exactly right it it you know i i'm
hopeful
hopeful that he's turned his life around
and he can maybe get out there and play
it's been a tough situation
it really has and it's been a little
unfair to him in a lot of ways so
uh we'll see but yeah that's going to be
interesting with some teams needy for
wide receivers
where you want to go with the power
rankings x what else you want to talk
about yeah you know i i don't know that
was a good conversation i forgot where
you're even talking about the power
rankings let's look at the back half
let's see who's lurking and see if
there's any hope for some of these teams
to maybe
snap out of it over the balance of the
season where where did
you're like 19 with your 49ers right the
49ers to me right now are like one of
the most confusing teams
you know in football i i don't you know
i don't know what to think i know
they're talented when they're healthy
and everything like that
uh it seems like they are getting
healthy i think they figured out some of
the issues with their defense that we
saw in the dolphins game that was
horrible two weeks ago
and then they come out and kick the crap
out of the rams for the most part in
that game who's
11. like did you have a hard time
figuring out where the hell you want to
put the 49ers yes
yeah i wanted to move them higher than
19 right there's the dolphins at 18 and
they just beat him 43-17 a week and a
half ago i didn't want to have a
thousand emails from dolphins fans
saying what the hell
or something stronger than that yeah i
i i get it i do i mean that's where
i look at the 49ers and go okay you know
and i'm not trying to be
disrespectful you know the raiders at
three and two you know the browns at
four and two the panthers at three and
three
you know i think they're better than
those teams i mean i i feel like they
are but you're right it's hard to pull
the trigger and you necessarily
put them in front of them with you know
not the most quality looking wins
and being kind of all over the place
like the potential of them is still top
ten
who's gonna show up yeah which team's
gonna show up the team that beat the
rams in prime time or the team that lost
back-to-back games
to the eagles and got blown off the
field by the dolphins yeah
which team is it going to be i know so
that's why they're kind of middle of the
pack and that's why their hard
sealing for now is the miami dolphins
because the dolphins have the same
record
and the dolphins destroyed them
dismantled them
i could not put them ahead of the
dolphins and i couldn't justify moving
the dolphins any higher so that's how
they ended up
sticking at number uh 19. yeah so
look it's tough between 10 and 20 well
yeah it's tough we don't know who's
gonna rise up out of that mess
and here's the thing every year there's
a team that ends up lurking around
five and five thanksgiving-ish and they
they start winning games they get into
that they get into that
it's really the playoffs even though it
isn't right right and they know they've
got a limited window of opportunity
so they start winning and winning and
winning and then they carry that into
the postseason that's what the patriots
did in 2001
yes when they lost to the rams in prime
time on a sunday night
at home they felt a five and five and
then after that
often and it ended yeah beating the rams
in the super bowl yeah well i mean
i i think that's why you got the
patriots at number 12 right now right i
mean that's what you kind of
i hear you there that was probably
another team hard to do in the top 20.
because
you go damn there's two they're two and
three they're certainly better teams
with better records you know they lose
to broncos we know they're
better than denver you know they really
weren't stopped in the game it was just
one mistake after another holy cow
uh i mean yeah i give you credit for
putting them at 12
because i think they're three losses i
mean two of them are against really
really good teams
and then yeah last week was unusual
circumstances as well
um where i i'm with you i think they're
one of those teams that is better than
their record that's for sure
and and think about this we've we've
reached the consensus on the best four
teams right now in the afc the ravens
the titans the steelers and the chiefs
not in that order
the one team that none of those four
will want to see in january
in their first playoff game they're made
for the playoffs right they're made for
the playoffs
because it's game plan specific stuff
they can run the football
and they can do things on defense to
shut down certain areas
to see where it goes the big thing with
the patriots going forward
just something to watch out for all
those people out there whatever
it's just connect this is where i'm
concerned especially this week
49ers coming to town shanahan run game
the the the patriots have an issue there
they do they don't have enough big
people on their
roster they don't have enough defensive
tackles mike they were playing
chase vinovich a defensive tackle in the
3-4 richard seymour
spot the other day i mean they were
having plays where dietrich wise at 265
pounds is playing
three technique you know that's why
phillip lindsey ran for some 100
something yards like
that to me is troubling a little bit to
where they're gonna have to figure that
out
sign somebody else make a trade whatever
but they lack
big people to where that could be one of
their kryptonites here going forward
and bill belichick was talking about
that run game yesterday and it was not
the lew holt's perfunctory
you know flowery stuff it was real
concern about what they do and how they
get the ball into so many different
players hands and how they keep
everything moving and everyone guessing
and it's really going to be a challenge
to the patriots this weekend
and and we will feel very differently
about the 49ers if they can go into new
england and win there
uh like they did the last time they went
to new england in 2012 when colin
kaepernick yeah i was there
i was there that was a that was uh that
was a hell of a game
on a sunday night uh in in december i
think it was of 2012 one of the greatest
teams i've ever seen in my
life in person mike just one of the
greatest physical specimen teams you'll
ever see in your life that 2012
2011 2013 49er team navarro bowman and
willis and you know justin smith and
i'm missing other guys on the defense
they had but they were just
unbelievable looking their offensive
line kaepernick was impressive i mean
they had alton smith oh alden smith too
holy crap
i mean they were they were just all
across the board it was one stud out it
was one of those where they got off the
bus
and i'll go back to something you've
heard me say where i went whoa if a bar
fight breaks out between all 32 teams in
football i know who's winning it's going
to be the 49ers uh
that was a cool game to watch and you
know what when you reflect on that grand
scheme of things eight years ago wasn't
really all that long
it is stunning to think how dramatically
nfl rosters
turn over it is in what is for the rest
of us
not all that long of a period of time no
but in the nfl
every year there's churn and you look
back four five six years and
you got a completely different team yeah
than you had just a half a decade ago
all right let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports